next few weeks are typically when
families start stocking up on candy and
picking out their costumes for halloween
you see it in all the stores right now
but the pandemic has made for some
uncertainty just ahead of the spooky
season
now in l.a county trick-or-treating is
not recommended but there's still no
word yet
if southern nevada could have the same
sort of forecast
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
is just outside of a valley costume
store
she's already in the halloween spirit
and she's that finding out that people
are actually shopping is that a unicorn
you're wearing sally
this is the fantastic 8 news now unicorn
and although some areas like l.a county
just as you mentioned
are definitely not recommending
trick-or-treating this year
there is hope here in the valley and
it's not stopping many from finding that
perfect halloween costume
usually halloween is just bustling this
year
it's going to be challenging michelle
pignatello is the owner of black cat
costumes and novelties
she knows that due to kova 19 many
events are canceled
and people are taking extra precautions
she is too making sure customers who
don't want to come inside her shop
can buy through her website and pick it
up curbside we're open all year
so we have halloween costumes all year
round for not only kids
but adults too we sell a lot of masks we
sell a lot of
makeup effects prosthetics props
decorations
wigs costumes i know
finances are really hard for everyone
out there so we're trying to have
something for everybody
halloween is a very like exciting
experience because
i am a horror fan it's always been a big
thing for us my dad was born on
halloween
jordan mustin is already thinking of
safe and creative ways to hand out
treats
i just came up with a good idea putting
them in little baggies
each candy individual candy and then
giving them to them so you don't have to
put
their hand in a bowl people are curious
i hope people celebrate halloween i
really you know
whether it's just in their homes or you
know just with one or two people
pignatello says although it hasn't been
as busy
as in previous years she hopes come
october
more will get in the halloween spirit
i'm old fashioned so it's
regardless of what's going on in the
world
we can't stop the holidays
[Applause]
so you may be asking what's trending
this year and store owner pignatello
tells me people are going more for the
nostalgic those old costumes that were
training in the past
along with creating those new costumes
you can make fun you can wear a nice fun
mask
with maybe a nice tutu reporting live
sally caramillo 8 news now